[Musique]
bonjour je viens j'aime bonjour moïse
bonjour à la martinique
merci d'être dans son caddie ce matin le
ppm l'une des composantes d'ensemble
pour une martinique nouvelle a forcément
le sourire de député de sénateur
avez-vous vous du nageur secrétaire
général du parti
avez vous l'impression d'avoir comblé le
retard d'avoir remis la balle au centre
d'être revenue dans le jeu avec à quatre
parlementaires
d'abord permettez moi d'avoir une pincée
vous gohi bi aujourd'hui qui est coupé
de la martinique ans expirait
effectivement que ça ne dure pas et que
à la fois laisse couler à mes 20 mai
tableau de l'ensemble de la commune
puissent est rattachée à la martinique
correctement malgré les aides en paix
vit maintenant je pense qu'il faut
simplement parler de satisfaction mais
de satisfaction mesurée l'important
c'est de pouvoir démontrer qu'il ya une
confiance qui t'habille à la forme avec
le peuple à travers les législatives
mais également avec les territoires à
travers les sénatoriales
donc aujourd'hui il ya une vraie
résistance qui s'est organisée autour de
l'alliance pour offrir une vraie
alternative les deux vraies perspectives
pour la martinique
et donc c'est dans ce sens que nous
continuons à construire nous sommes
remis en question dans votre travail et
nous avons revu ensemble les éléments
notre cohérence nous avons consolidé
nous avons également renforcé avec
beaucoup de jeunes je rappelle qu'au
parti progressiste martiniquais
aujourd'hui
l'organe de direction est composée à 80
% de jeunes et de nouveaux et beaucoup
de femmes
donc il faut les former les préparer à
ce qu'ils puissent devenir demain
l'élite politique de la matinée qui a
vraiment de quoi en tirer gloire les
parlementaires c'est bon c'est bon pour
le prestige c'est bon également pour les
rentrées d'argent en vue de financer le
parti c'est quand même un joli trésor de
guerre n'avait pas le nier mais pour le
reste l'image du parlementaire c'est
quand même un peu écornée auprès du
grand public
écoutez c'est parce que l'image du
parlementaire et hop à distance puisque
le parlementaire va surtout défend de la
martinique au niveau de la france
hexagonale aussi bien au niveau de
l'assemblée nationale qu'au niveau du
sénat et vous avez vu l'état de la
martinique
b vous savez c'est un combat vous avez
six parlementaires sur à peu près 577
députés à peu près 300
sénateurs donc c'est un combat de tous
les jours mais il faut suivre aussi
c'est vrai quoi on est plus préoccupé
par les réalités locales sans se rendre
compte que les décisions qui se prennent
au niveau de la fouace hexagonale a eu
mille kilomètres en des incidences
directes
je prends un exemple tout savoir de
finances qui va être votée là à des as
in asia que la décision de suppression
des contrats aidés qui s'est fait à 8000
km sans concertation de manière
strictement unilatérale a eu des
conséquences directes
donc il faut passer par le passé en
pointe cette année 10 1 euros le plus
distant les promesses de proximité
puisque il est même quelque chose de
majeur est devenu une évidence c'est que
les parlementaires de martinique ne
savent pas y aller ensemble avec le même
costume
le même maillot mais c'est toujours
cette problématique aujourd'hui il ya
ceux qui cherchent à diviser a chuté sas
à rassembler de manière du corps de ceux
qui voudraient s'y est écouté
aujourd'hui on voit bien que six
parlementaires la martinique les
martiniquaises les martiniquais les
territoires ont décidé d'avoir quatre
parlementaires de la même couleur
politique donc tu dois certainement le
meilleur unités une meilleure
mobilisation face aux enjeux d'avenir
pour la martinique dont nous sommes en
matière d'emploi et de développement
vous allez pouvoir vous imposer
jean philippe miller est à bout du nez
ce tracé les écouter choix il suivre ils
suivent le le train qui est parti qui
qui qui vous regarde l'avenir qui fait
des propositions
la logique politique n'est pas
simplement d'écouter ou de d'apparaître
la logique politique c'est de pouvoir
faire des propositions concrètes en
matière de projets en matière
d'initiatives en matière de libération
d'énergie en matière de développement
économique pour régler les différents
problèmes que nous vivons au quotidien
donc il faut entrer dans cette dynamique
là il suffit pas d'apparaître d'exister
et de dieu je suis à l'assemblée
nationale et l'état d'esprit aujourd'hui
comment le jauger vous bon c'est vrai
que les élections sénatoriales sont
toutes récentes ca d'apple ne même pas
quelques jours mais vous pensez qu'il ya
un état d'esprit qui irait dans ce sens
devrait pour la martinique de la part de
des parlementaires que nous connaissons
mais écoutez de toutes les origines a
repris à zéro
nous espérons qu'ils rentreront dans
cette dynamique puisque aujourd'hui la
martinique est à l'arrêt faut pas le
nier regardez encore les derniers
chiffres du chômage au gardien dans les
derniers indicateurs de lier d'hommes la
situation se dégrade considérablement et
nous sommes en train de réduire nos
capacités d'investissement
d'investissement pardon parce que nous
n'investissons pas si vous voulez vous
avez un stock d'argent qui est là
mais si il pas café pythie s'il nous
crée pas de richesse d'ailleurs tu y
stocke claquer 10 minutes mais qu'elle
était rien demain situation
catastrophique donc faut que nous il est
vrai connu jeudi à nyon combat à mener
sur les trois années qui viennent
parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya aucune
politique publique en faveur de
l'intérêt général en faveur des classes
moyennes en faveur des classes
défavorisées en faveur de l'activité du
pays que sauve ses députés que savent
ces sénateurs de ce que les martiniquais
veulent pour la martinique où des
cocktails la majorité de ses
parlementaires ont été maires ils ont la
notion de la proximité donc ils
connaissent les problématiques de
proximité en fonction des secteurs
donc ils sont cette réalité qui est à la
fois territoriale mais aussi global qui
est martiniquaise donc nous avons besoin
d'outils au service du développement
nous avons besoin d'idées nous avons
besoin de libérer l'initiative et nous
avons besoin d'avoir une unité et une
mobilisation pour montrer justement la
france hexagonale que nous avons cette
capacité de nous gérer et de faire en
sorte que les solutions qui sont en nous
mêmes puissent être concrète et se
réaliser simplement avec un
accompagnement au niveau de l'état sans
que ça soit des demandes pour demander
l'agencé passe à nous demander 100 km et
ses capacités à j baby notre capacité
d'agir pour le pays il ya tellement de
choses qui ne vont pas un je veux pas
revenir sur le tcsp tellement cette
question devient ridicule aujourd'hui
cette capacité de d'agir pour le pays
oui on a ça mais vu l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
justement nous écouter vous savez face à
des situations il ya plusieurs postures
la posture qui consiste en qui continua
a consisté à diviser vous savez là
aujourd'hui
la martinique est face à deux idéologies
très clair l'idéologie de la dépendance
a des manques à bord l'agenda agents
publics qui bat à mains c'est au niveau
de la ctm que ça se passe on distribue
de l'argent simplement pour dire que on
va satisfaire des besoins immédiats mais
récurrence et à l'échappement gobbi
j'aime aider les gens dans mon cabinet
indépendant d'ilotes là ce qui fait que
tous les six ans et type takkari
visualiser ce que vous pensez de la 7e
c'est ce que je pense de la ctm
aujourd'hui c'est donner du poisson avec
l'argent public des impôts des
martiniquais sans jamais réussir
et puis vous avez 2 et mythologies pas
lorsque vous êtes sur demande écoutez
non vous savez et des socialement
ponctuellement
un sens mais permettra qu'à la personne
de s'émanciper de s'épanouir et de
pouvoir avoir son propre salaire pour
pouvoir décider de ce qu'elle va faire
de son budget et je vais sa famille
c'est autre chose
nous sommes dans la capacité dans la
volonté nous dans l'autre idéologie de
vouloir plutôt apprendre à pêcher c'est
à dire que chaque mineur à des bouillies
coolio bien sûr il faut impulser une
image dynamique il faut être moteur et
c'est dans ce sens que permettre à
chacun d'être autonomes à la fois
individuellement et collectivement
c'est la clé de la création de richesse
et de la capacité pour la martinique
avant une personnalité collective et à
faire en sorte qu'elles puissent quelles
que soient les difficultés et les
obstacles réussir elle a passé toutes
les épreuves devant lesquelles va se
retrouver les élections de dimanche
dernier les sénatoriales ont sacré
catherine conconne mais il ya quand même
une blessure nomi ils vont pas quitter
que se passera-t-il pour l'ancien
secrétaire général de votre parti le
fidèle militant convaincu que son heure
était arrivée
fort de sa grande expérience écoutez le
ppm est aujourd'hui dans une phase de
dimension collective il faut surtout ne
pas stigmatiser ou regarder des
individualités
le bpm vargas avoir pas mal de dix vit
du à l'événement le pb en fait on ne va
pas parler d'une personne parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'importance et l'intérêt
supérieur de la martinique c'est le
collectif
donc il ya une convention et le ppn
n'est pas le genre de parti qui prend
des décisions de manière unilatérale
sans organisation dont nous allons
organiser une convention avec nos
militants avec nos sympathisants et nous
allons décider certainement de modifier
un certain nombre de points du règlement
intérieur vous fait en sorte que la
notion de congé du parti qui n'existe
pas dans les statuts mais qui se
pratiquent de manière naturelle puisse
disparaître définitivement at il bien
voilà il suffit que des intérêts
personnels soit soit mieux mis en avant
et ça écrase ses glands dizaines de
personnalités à s'être mis en congé
avoir soutenu des adversaires politiques
que vous aviez dessiner au sein du ppm
au sein des mondial de l'alliance
honnêtement c'est la vie politique vous
savez dans tous les préparatifs
peut-être encore plus au parti
progressiste martiniquais il ya de très
fortes personnalités mais ça dure depuis
un certain temps johnny gère ça veut
dire que vous n'êtes pas capables de
frapper très fort sur la table pour dire
ça suffit on arrête ce jeu loc
la discipline est une règle
favre ont fait respecter les règles nous
les avons maintenant s'ils appliquent
cette affaire où le salaire j'ai fait et
je prends le voir ses plumes héros
l'autorité est en marche il faut bien
comprendre que nous ne pouvons pas
décider et je ne déciderai pas seule je
suis pas le secrétaire général en
décidant tout seul dans mon coin
il y à une équipe bien comité national
et un bureau politique qui a des
balisiers comme je vous le dis la
convention servira de régler un certain
nombre de points deux points d'un
certain nombre de décisions parce qu'il
y aura des délibérations qui sont prises
au niveau de cette convention qui vont
s'appliquer immédiatement
et à partir de ces de ses délibérations
se sera pas la parole d'une personne
c'est pas un monde par rapport à loeb
c'est en partie par rapport à des
individualités et tous les cas seront
examinés une râpe à eux qui sera
volontairement ou accidentellement
oublié il ne s'agit pas de traiter des
cas il s'agit de régler des problèmes du
règlement intérieur qui feront qu'il y
aura plus de cas individuels ou en tout
cas qu'on fera en sorte que ces cas
disparaisse définitivement
mais la logique et de tout régler en un
seul coup avec l'aval de tous en
concertation en toute démocratie et en
toute transparence les municipales sont
déjà dans toutes les têtes même s'ils
n'y aura pas d'élection pas avant deux
ans vous avez y travailler nous
travaillons à la relève ne travaillant à
la formation
nous travaillons à l'éveil des
consciences nous travaillons
l'émancipation travail et à
l'épanouissement individuel et collectif
aujourd'hui nous avons un vivier de
jeunes nous avons un vivier de femmes il
faut les former il faut les préparer à
occuper la relève de demain quand vous
parlez de votre chien solide et une
certaine devons laisser la place écoutez
c'est le calcul ça a été le cas le
nombre de mandats effectués
là j'y allais il y à déjà il y à déjà
dans le statut la limite sous le cumul
des mandats d'ailleurs j'ai démissionné
en tant que membre de la cacem parce que
justement je me retrouvais avec trois
fonctions oui et donc même si légalement
ou juridiquement je n'avais pas
l'obligation je les fais parce que
statutairement au niveau de mon parti
n'avait ont considéré que le mandat de
conseiller communautaire comme un mandat
supplémentaire donc il va falloir aussi
libérer des places pour permettre un
maximum à la fois de jeunes et de femmes
de pouvoir également participé et
contribué à au développement de ce pays
au projet martinique et à relever se
payer aujourd'hui qui est en train de
chuter
merci beaucoup je dis aux joueurs
d'avoir été ce matin dans son crédit on
rappelle que vous êtes le secrétaire
général du parti progressiste
martiniquais
bonne journée broken ainsi bonne journée
bon
qu'il dégage